[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen an meiner seite ist für den
sport norbert könig guten abend und wir
haben unter anderem diese themen für sie
wieder proteste in glasgow
umweltschützer kritisieren die
halbzeitbilanz der weltklimakonferenz
messerangriff im ece ein mann sticht auf
passagiere ein und verletzt sie schwer
und weg mit der maroden infrastruktur
einer autobahnbrücke in wiesbaden wurde
erfolgreich gesprengt
wäre der klimawandel ein fußballspiel
dann läge die menschheit 1 zu 5 zurück
das sagte der britische premier johnson
zu beginn des weltklimagipfels vor einer
woche zur halbzeit stellt sich jetzt die
frage was die fast 40.000 teilnehmer
bisher geschafft haben um aufzuholen
viel zu wenig sagen klimaschützer und
machen auch heute wieder druck mit
weltweiten protesten aus glasgow volker
anders
glasgow innenstadt die demonstranten
fordern auch heute wieder mehr tempo
beim klimaschutz
wir können nur hoffen darum sind wir
hier wir wollen veränderungen zum guten
sie
hören einfach auf die falschen leute sie
hören auf die milliardäre und eben nicht
auf menschen die unter dem klimawandel
leiden
strikt nach plan nach den vorgaben des
pariser klimaschutzabkommens wird im
konferenzzentrum verhandelt lang ist der
zeitplan für die meetings kompliziert
sind die verhandlungen im detail
am ende der ersten woche kristallisieren
sich drei wesentliche noch nicht
abgeschlossene punkte heraus und zwar
regeln für internationale klimaschutz
kooperationen zustande kommen der
klimaschutz finanzierung für
entwicklungsländer fertigstellung der
transparenz mechanismen
und die werden in diesem 80 seitigen
text verhandelt
in paris haben wir uns vereinbart dass
alle staaten ihre ziele selber bestimmen
und dann nach gleichen formaten darüber
berichten und diese formate haben wir
jetzt entwickelt die britische regierung
will mit länder partnerschaften punkten
neben den eigentlichen verhandlungen zum
pariser klimaschutzabkommen vor allem
kohle ausstieg und heute neue mehr geld
für den naturschutz bisher noch ohne
umsetzungs garantie wir erwarten dass am
ende dieser konferenz hier ein
überprüfungs rahmen beschlossen wird
damit man dem wirklich auf den zahn
fühlen kann man muss wissen ist dass
ernst ist das greenwashing halbzeit auf
der klimakonferenz alle wissen macht
bitte schnell die zeit drängt
fragen wir unseren umweltexperten volker
angriffs vor ort wie werten sie die
halbzeitbilanz in glasgow im vergleich
zu den vorgänger treffen spürt man da
den größeren druck
ja ich denke schon der einigungswille
ist deutlich spürbar größer geworden und
das ist glaube ich auch ganz gut zu
erklären denn auch die klimabedingten
katastrophen sind mehr geworden wir zu
hause haben sie einmal gesehen das ist
das eine und der druck der jungen leute
der druck der von freiheits for future
und anderen gruppierungen kommt er ist
gewachsen und das dritte der dritte
punkt ist dass die erneuerbaren energien
immer wirtschaftlich geworden und sind
und von daher gesehen wären die ausreden
immer dünner eben nichts zu tun wichtig
ist aber wir sind hier tatsächlich unter
dem abkommen von paris und das wird im
stück für stück abgearbeitet das gefällt
den jungen leuten natürlich überhaupt
nicht aber dieses regime diesen vorgang
jetzt aufzumachen und neu zu verhandeln
das wäre ganz ganz schlecht das würde
niemals gelingen und der zweite punkt
ist diese bilateralen neun projekte die
hier die präsidentschaft der konferenz
auf den weg gebracht hat die müssen sich
erst noch beweisen sollten die in die
umsetzung gehen dann könnte es nächste
woche tatsächlich fortschritte geben
meine woche es noch zeit vielen dank
nach glasgow volker anders
interessante berechnungen zum
klimawandel finden sie auch online auf
unserer zdf heute app zum beispiel wo in
deutschland könnte es künftig mehr heiße
tage geben oder in welchen regionen
sollte man mit mehr starkregen rechnen
jetzt zu corona da verschafft sich die
situation weiter das robert koch
institut meldet 34.000 zwei neue
infektionen innerhalb eines tages
12459 mehr als vor einer woche die
sieben tage incidents steigt deutlich
auf jetzt
183,7 einen vollständigen impfschutz
haben inzwischen 55 8 millionen menschen
also
67,1 prozent
das sind immer noch zu wenig um die
vierte welle zu brechen fordert jetzt
auch der ärzteverband marburger bund
eine impfpflicht für bestimmte
berufsgruppen und zwar für alle die in
medizinischen einrichtungen kitas
schulen oder altersheimen arbeiten zudem
wird versucht den zugang zum impfen für
alle so einfach wie möglich zu gestalten
in braunschweig zum beispiel mit einem
infomobil vor der moschee peter kunz
das mobile im team vor der moschee in
braunschweig baut noch auf da wartet
schon der erste mit gebetsteppich und
impfbuch nach sechs monaten möchte abdel
asis errani die dritte impfung
viele andere hier nicht nur muslime
wollen auch die von jens spahn
versprochene booster impfung bekommen
sie vor der tür zur moschee sowie
abdirahman zakaria seine erste dosis ich
wollte das eigentlich früher lange hier
machen aber das halt so immer weil ich
arbeiten und ich habe keine zeit gehabt
und so er sei in probezeit bei der
volkswagen werks feuerwehr sagt abdi
rachman dafür muss er geimpft sein
impfung in kombination mit dem
freitagsgebet als gute gelegenheit
überall hingehen wo man noch menschen
von der impfung überzeugen kann gegen
ängste und vorurteile
mitunter gibt es gerüchte wer geimpft
ist wird abgeschoben
etwa bei den flüchtlingsunterkünften
oder was ich eben erwähnte das können
die unfruchtbar machen von daher
versuchen wir natürlich auch an orten zu
sein denen ein gewisser vertrauter
rahmen da ist in dem auch die menschen
sehen na ja nicht nur ich lasse mich
impfen andere tun das auch
eine hohe im stich in dieser moschee
[Gelächter]
wir sind schließlich teil dieser
gesellschaft und die freiheit eines
einzelnen endet wo die freiheit der
anderen anfängt impfung für jedermann
vor der moschee in braunschweig das
modell zieht fast 300 dosen in vier
stunden verbraucht
messerangriff auf fahrgäste dieser
notrufe aus einem ic löste am morgen
einen großeinsatz der bayerischen
polizei aus in einem gut besetzten zug
hatte ein mann mehrere fahrgäste
attackiert und drei von ihnen schwer
verletzt
der mutmaßliche angreifer ein 27
jähriger syrer konnte bald darauf
überwältigt werden brigitte sa berichtet
bislang sprechen die ermittler nicht von
einem terroristischen angriff und auch
nicht von einem politischen motiv der
täter ist angeblich 2014 als flüchtlinge
aus syrien nach deutschland gekommen
fest steht der ungefähre tathergang im
ic zwischen regensburg und nürnberg
heute morgen gegen 9 geht der 27 jährige
mit einem messer auf mehrere mitreisende
los und verletzt drei männer schwer es
besteht der anfangsverdacht versuchter
tötungsdelikte und diesbezüglich werden
die ermittlungen auch geführt der täter
kann noch im zug festgenommen werden die
spurensicherung untersucht den tatort
die kripo regensburg hat die
ermittlungen übernommen
bundesinnenminister seehofer reagiert
bestürzt
die grausame messerattacke im ic ist
furchtbar ich hoffe dass die verletzten
und diejenigen die das geschehen
miterleben mussten schnell und
vollständig gesund werden
der zug wurde im bahnhof von seibersdorf
evakuiert ein kriseninterventionsteam
steht bereit um fahrgäste psychologisch
zu betreuen
die meisten der mehr als 200 passagiere
konnten ihre reise inzwischen mit bussen
fortsetzen die gesperrte bahnstrecke ist
gerade erst wieder für den verkehr
freigegeben worden
in die usa dort kämpft präsident beiden
seit monaten um seine zentralen
wahlversprechen auch gegen widerstand
aus seiner eigenen partei jetzt hat er
zumindest eines seiner
investitionspakete durch den us kongress
gebracht in den nächsten jahren soll
mehr als eine billion dollar in
infrastruktur fließen also in verkehr
breitbandausbau wasser und stromnetze
benjamin daniel
als joe biden vor wenigen stunden vor
die kameras tritt kann er seine
erleichterung nicht verbergen das
repräsentantenhaus verabschiedete
endlich sein infrastrukturpaket sogar
mit 13 stimmen der republikaner
für die meisten jobs die wir hiermit
schaffen braucht man keinen
uni-abschluss es wird neue jobs im
ganzen land geht in republikanischen und
demokratischen staaten in städten und
kleineren orten mit diesem plan stärken
wir die mittelklasse und bauen amerika
wieder auf
mehr als eine billion dollar gegen
marode brücken strassen ein veraltetes
gas strom und wassernetz oder für den
breitbandausbau der us präsident kann
das gesetz nun unterschreiben nach
monatelangem ringen gerade auch mit dem
linken flügel seiner eigenen partei laut
dem weißen haus soll es millionen
arbeitsplätze schaffen und den usa
helfen sich im wirtschafts wettlauf mit
china durchzusetzen
es ist vielleicht kein befreiungsschlag
aber doch ein ganz wichtiger etappensieg
für joe biden denn nun hat er ein
kernvorhaben seiner präsidentschaft so
gut wie in trockenen tüchern gerade nach
der pleite der demokraten bei den
gouverneurswahlen in virginia hat er
diesen teilerfolg dringend gebraucht die
abstimmung über beides anderes noch
größeres billionen vorhaben wurde
verschoben dieser plan sieht 1,75
millionen dollar für den ausbau des
sozialsystems vor und für den kampf
gegen den klimawandel
auch hier wird der us-präsident in den
nächsten wochen vor allem seine eigenen
leute überzeugen müssen
tragisches ende eines musikfestivals in
der us stadt houston bei einer
massenpanik wurden mindestens acht
menschen getötet mehr als 300 verletzt
die panik brach aus beim auftritt des
rappers travis gott als sich die
zuschauer vor der bühne drängen
nach ersten angaben sollen viele der
opfer sehr jung gewesen seien einige
erst zehn jahre alt bei der explosion
eines tanklasters sind im
westafrikanischen sierra leone etwa 100
menschen ums leben gekommen viele
weitere wurden schwer verletzt
ein lkw hatte den laster an einer
tankstelle in der hauptstadt freetown
gerammt zahlreiche menschen versuchten
offenbar das auslaufende benzin
aufzufangen
als der laster explodierte
zurück nach deutschland wie marode die
deutschen autobahnen und vor allem deren
brücken sind zeigte sich heute in
wiesbaden
dort musste mit der salzbach talbrücke
eine zentrale verkehrsader gesprengt
werden nur die spitze des eisbergs
warnen fachleute in ganz deutschland
gelten rund 3000 autobahnbrücken mehr
oder weniger als renovierungsbedürftig
also etwa jede zehnte über die sprengung
in wiesbaden peter theißen
ein lauter knall dann ist sie weg die
salzbach talbrücke aus dem jahr 1963
vergangenheit im juni waren plötzlich
betonbrocken abgebrochen und
heruntergestürzt die marode nicht mehr
zu rettende brücke sinnbild für die
vernachlässigte infrastruktur in
deutschland
wir haben bisher rund 200
autobahnbrücken sogar ein bisschen
weniger pro jahr in ordnung gebracht und
wir werden in zukunft rund 400
autobahnbrücken pro jahr in ordnung
bringen müssen das bedeutet eine
erhöhung der dazu notwendigen
personellen und materiellen und auch
finanziellen ressourcen
es sind vor allem autobahnbrücken im
westen der republik die gerade saniert
oder gar neu gebaut werden müssen denn
die meisten wurden zwischen den 60er und
80er jahren errichtet sind in die jahre
gekommen wir haben eine güterverkehrs
entwicklung die vor 50 60 jahren in der
form noch nicht absehbar war
gleichzeitig und das muss man auch
zugeben hatten wir in der vergangenheit
vor allen dingen eine investitions
politik nach kassenlage
in wiesbaden sollen die 15.000 tonnen
schutt nun schnell beiseite geschafft
werden damit wenigstens bis weihnachten
wieder züge nach wiesbaden rollen können
die neue autobahnbrücke aber wird wohl
frühestens 2023 befahrbar sein
grill und genial sagen leser über seine
werke ein sprachkünstler der
grenzbereiche erkunde sagt die deutsche
akademie für sprache und dichtung über
clemens johann setz und ehrte den
österreichischen schriftsteller vor
knapp einer stunde mit dem
georg-büchner-preis der bedeutendsten
literarischen auszeichnung im
deutschsprachigen raum der 38 jährige
setz studierte germanistik und
mathematik und gilt als literarisches
wunderkind
das übrigens erst 16 die lust am lesen
entdeckte die deutschen tennis fans
haben auf ein großes finale gehofft aber
wird nichts wäre ist ausgeschieden hat
verloren in paris es ist wie im
richtigen leben auch ein top profi hat
mal einen schlechten tag und deshalb
verliert schwere glasklar gingen daniel
medwedew und darum spielt die nummer
zwei der welt morgen gegen die nummer
eins novak djokovic
so viel hatte zf länger nicht zu grübeln
nach einer 2 1 führung verliert mehr und
mehr den faden und schließlich auch den
ersten satz mit 2 6 gegen den immer
stärker werdenden russen gegen den er im
vorjahr hier in paris im finale
unterlegen war als zweite nach ungewohnt
fehlerhaft dem spiel im zweiten satz ein
frühes break kassiert ist es um seine
fassung geschehen nach knapp
eineinviertel stunden endet sein pariser
auftritt mit 2 6 und 2 6
medwedew gewinnt zum vierten mal
nacheinander gegen den müde wirkenden
olympiasieger aus hamburg der nach
seinem sieg in wien vor sechs tagen die
chance auf seinen sechsten titelgewinn
in diesem jahr verpasst hat
der fc bayern münchen hat die
erfolgsserie des sc freiburg in der
fußball bundesliga beendet die
breisgauer kassieren in der münchner
arena ihre erste saison niederlage
durch treffer von goretzka und
lewandowski gewinnt der rekordmeister
mit 2 zu 1 habe das gegentor erst in der
nachspielzeit matcher beschert wolfsburg
gegen augsburg den dritten
pflichtspielsieg nacheinander und ogawa
besiegelt mit seinem treffer bielefelds
auswärtssieg in stuttgart und der vfl
bochum gewinnt 2 zu 0 gegen hoffenheim
am abend leipzig gegen dortmund
ausführlich und sportstudio gestern
mainz mönchengladbach 113 spiele morgen
dortmund kann wieder auf einen punkt an
die bayern heranrücken freiburg bleibt
dritter jetzt vor wolfsburg dahinter
kann es noch bewegung im tabellenbild
geben auch in der unteren hälfte können
vier teams noch punkten bielefeld hat
mit dem ersten saisonsieg anschluss
gefunden greuther fürth will auch
endlich drei punkte zum schluss des
elften spieltages morgen gegen frankfurt
freiburgs trainer christian streich wird
ab 23 uhr 30 im aktuellen sportstudio
erzählen wie er mit der ersten saison
niederlage im topspiel beim fc bayern um
geht der fc barcelona
letzter gruppengegner des fcb in der
champions league hat einen neuen trainer
für 1 legende charlie ist vorzeitig von
seinem arbeitgeber in katar freigegeben
worden und noch ein ergebnis von der
kurzbahn schwimm europameisterschaft in
kasan russland dort hat marco koch über
200 meter brust den sechsten platz
belegt koch auf bahn eins ganz oben und
vor zwei jahren dritter fehlen nach zwei
minuten 51 3 sekunden mehr als drei
sekunden auf einen medaillenrang
europameister wird ilja shimano witsch
ausbildungs und
fertig geschrieben dankeschön jedes mal
aufs neue hat etwas was schon
zauberhaftes der erste schöne schnee des
jahres bis in die täler hatte es zwar
noch nicht geschafft aber immerhin auf
den fichtelberg im erzgebirge
genug zum staunen und für alles kreative
und allemal genug um auch wintermuffel
daran zu erinnern wie strahlen selbst
die dunkelste zeit des jahres sein kann
morgen gibt es noch ein bisschen sonne
aber von norden zieht tief rudolf auf
mehr dazu hat gleich katja honnefer das
heute-journal nach wetten dass um
viertel nach elf mit claus kleber wir
danken für ihr interesse und wünschen
ihnen noch ein unbeschwertes wochenende
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend international hat das
unwetter tief bei den balearen einen
namen bekommen auf unser wetter hat es
keinen einfluss anders als das tiefe
rudolph das bringt seine kaltfront schon
heute nacht so und so die zieht dann
morgen weiter nach südosten heute nacht
kann es also ergiebig regnen und zwar
zwischen berlin und der ruhr etwa
nördlich davon gibt's auch starkem bis
stürmischem südwestwind im süden ist es
dagegen klar und da bildet sich auch mal
nebel und dann wird es kalt dann sinken
die temperaturen auf plus 4 bis minus
sechs grad unter den regenwolken im
norden bleibt es bei zehn bis sieben
grad milder und morgen liegen die
höchsttemperaturen zwischen 5 und 12
grad und der regen der nacht zieht etwas
weiter nach süden mittags siegte dann
etwa zwischen dem erzgebirge und dem
saarland dahinter lockern die wolken
schon wieder auf es gibt kräftige
schauer und gewitter bei einem starken
bis stürmischen westwind am längsten
werden sie die sonne wohl am alpenrand
sehen können am montag fällt noch etwas
regen in deutschland danach aber setzt
sich schönes novemberwetter durch bei
sechs bis zwölf grad und mit diesem
schönen blick über die schneebedeckte
alpengipfel von der zugspitze heute
mittag wünsche ich ihnen jetzt ein
schönes wochenende